lorsque la mosquée de bayonne a été
attaquée et que j'ai compris que
quelqu'un avait tiré sur deux vieilles
personnes des fidèles juste parce que
c'était des musulmans et qu'ils allaient
juste à leurs mosquées
je me suis dit c'est pas possible je me
suis dit c'est pas possible on peut pas
on peut pas laisser faire ça moi j'avais
envie et j'habitais belges habitent
comme vous savez à bagnolet j'ai jamais
très près à côté de la mosquée et je me
suis dit mais il faut va aller faire
rempart il faut aller tout se mettre
ensemble autour de la mosquée et dire
pas touche
vous arrêtez maintenant avec votre
délire de guerre civile parce qu'il ya
des gens en france et ça c'est une
réalité faut pas être naïf par rapport à
ça les amis il y en a qui veulent la
guerre civile
ils sont à longueur d'antenne dans les
réunions à dire à mettre le poison de la
division ils veulent qu y ait des morts
ils veulent qui est des morts ok donc
nous notre travail à tous autant connaît
c'est d'être là avec notre drapeau blanc
1 et de dire à tout seul à tous ceux qui
veulent s'entretuent et non pas en
république
pas en france parce que nous avons
quelque chose de beaucoup plus fort
c'est l'amour de notre patrie
républicaine c'est notre rapport comment
à cette histoire à la révolution
française à la laïcité est bien
évidemment que si tu étais peut-être
plus fort si les institutions elles
mêmes avaient suscité une telle
manifestation
si depuis les talibans avaient appelé à
manifester avait pris les mairies ce que
vous auriez oui mais oui c'est à dire
que l'état lui même dit 10 bat faisons
quelque chose manifestants nous que les
grands partis institutionnels qui sont à
l'assemblée et au sénat par tous que eux
mêmes parce que vous dites là moi je
vous entends dire fallait pas manifestés
mais mai - moi je vous reproche vous
dans vos parties de ne pas avoir
organisé vous méritez
c'était une journée dans la partie pour
l'été les enfants et vous voulez vous
entre les vidéos des banques parole du
seuil et joie selon moi j'ai pas
beaucoup parler fini s'est même pas du
tout parler pour l'instant
alors bien sûr après il ya une liste de
signataires de gens qui prennent
l'initiative
bien sûr on peut être d'accord pas
d'accord et cetera mois à madjid
messaoudene on n'est pas super d'accord
sur plein de sujets bon mais commençait
à à mounir l'empathie qui était
naturelle naturelle chez chacun de nous
lorsqu'on a vu l'attentât fasciste de
bayonne parce que c'est ça il ya un mec
et former politiquement il est d'extrême
droite
il lit il a été candidat aux élections
pour l'extrême droite donc il pense le
truc et puis il se dit je vais aller
faire un attentat d'extrême droite c'est
d'un acte est bon et on est là dans une
empathie alors la caisse moment on a
tous les aboli soeur d'empathie surtout
n'ayons n'ayez pas d'empathie
vous avez plein la badr el kaddouri
c'est ce que vous dites toute la france
a soumis ce n'était pas là alors oui
c'est vrai pourquoi n'étiez pas là si
c'est aussi en clair que ça pour quoi
ils sont faits n'auraient pas le kiss in
g football et membre à notre tête nous
pourquoi la france a soumis ce n'était
pas la marche ben pardon elle l'était
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs qu'il était la
vedette dans toutes les familles il ya
plein de gens qui sont ici
qui ne veulent pas trop madjid jc penney
co dit on va venir
et puis ils seront personnellement moi
par exemple j'y étais j'ai appelé à y
aller j'ai dit elle dans l'est dans
l'immédiat pourquoi je dis allez j'y
étais mais bon je représente pas la
france sont soumises les gt logique avec
mon sentiment initial du lendemain de
l'attentât l'échangé de notes je note
noter quand même la grande hypocrisie
est vraiment le le lobby intellectuelle
dans laquelle nous sommes
vous avez vu là une de valeurs actuelles
mais est ce que ça prenne mélenchon
corbières matile panneaux et les copains
parce qu'ils étaient là répondre à la
crise et à meaux collabos alors là là
c'est pas une référence à la seconde
guerre mondiale à la chambre pour
répondre lâchez-moi super g catena ce
n'est pas jaune en faisant des tonnes
pour reprocher à des français de se
référer à la shoah pour un pour dire
plus jamais ça parce que mon corps
répond parce que tu as l'air bien d'en
verser l'eau adoucie du tord à l'homme
mais moi je veux souligner à quel point
j'en ai marre de cette hypocrisie tuer
j'en ai moi je suis bien c'est le pointu
vous l'avez tous fait des tonnes sur les
toits j'aurais dit normal ça fait les
personnes d'entre vous n'a parlé de cet
énorme assure la mlg où la vie si tu
veux pas qu'elle réponde à la question
d'eric naulleau pourquoi tout le monde a
annulé au dernier moment
la plupart la plupart la plus bas par
les natures de l'ific était la façade
quand même c'est comme clauberg demande
une sont pas venus ses mails en six mois
elle est plus qu il veut que tu admires
des moments at il pas de moi s'il ya eu
il ya pas debout
le groupe tout le groupe parlementaire
les sept membres du groupe par le fait
que l on appelait à l'appel ont mobilisé
pour la pelle dans tous les
interventions médias ils ont dit aux
gens allez-y face à des gens sains qu'il
a quitté à l'invers dizaine surtout pas
surtout pas n'y allez pas céder aux
pressions raison je ne crois pas je
pense moi ça m'a tellement je pense
vraiment qu adrien catena j'avais
quelque chose de très simple je vais il
a dit je vais donner la réponse à
l'élément parce qu'ils ont c'est le même
raisonnement que moi ils veulent bien
marché contre l'islamophobie mais pas
n'importe quel prix et pas payer la
cantine sanaa pour tenir bon et de la
réussite de la rue des bas et après on
passe à autre chose
et par ailleurs franchement recevoir des
leçons de quand tu manifestes quand ils
manifestent pas de la part de gens qui
de leur vie ont dû manifester deux fois
vous nous parler d'eric naulleau suffit
humain mais c'est bon paraît pas qu'on
vit ensemble et avoir la russie en gaz
et marseille elle est très belle dit
maintenant